welcome to a new video here on code tech
tutorials my name is matt all right
jumping in the middle of this because
uh okay so i recorded the whole thing
with terrible lagginess
um if you're having that laggy problem
uh what you can do
is go to properties and change your
video format to
one of these three if you have it on
this four by two by two one by default
it's really laggy for some reason
not sure why but i didn't realize that
until after i recorded
all of this so sorry about the laggy
video but how you fix it just change it
to one of these other video formats
and boom no lag everything's fine
everything's
man if only i knew this sooner i decided
i was going to try linux
this month again for the first time in a
while well i use it a little bit on one
of my laptops but i thought i'd try to
use it as my daily driver for a while
and just see how it went see if i can
get
my usual work done and what i tend to do
is a little bit of graphical programming
it's making videos studying computer
science topics
general uh research and
mostly just various programming and
video editing
and recording videos like this that's
what i mostly do on my computer
and and some gaming i tend to do a
little bit of
gaming as well so i basically tried to
do all those things and see if i could
do it
in an easy way
i'll say a few good things i did find
that in general i could actually get
work done
i could i can record videos i'm
recording one right now i was like okay
let's just let's just see if
valham's supposed to work properly on
linux
but here's what happens it just says
play valheim or play using opengl
well i don't know what this first option
means but if you hit it
it just it just crashes instantly so
okay
default option fails if you hit opengl
it does launch and i configured it a
little bit i turned down all the
settings which
you know i have a beast of a graphics
card in this computer
on windows i can crank the settings on
this game and still get decent frame
rates
but on linux
kind of loud sorry i don't know it might
be not i think i have it turned down for
you guys
but on linux like look at this frame
rate oh god
just lagging out everything uh i can't
even drag this over in obs
uh so let's let's talk about this little
software manager software
so the main one is this one or this one
let's look at
this one here all right well glaring
issues
why is weather in here twice maps in
here twice dictionary twice everything's
in here twice
like what what am i supposed to do with
that
do you have any idea how many times i've
downloaded and restarted
you can see from my last video kind of
what i had to go through to get obs even
working at
all so i could record videos at all
which is you know a base requirement for
me to use the os
so the drivers it comes with for nvidia
or these open source
ones however you say this nouveau
like if you try to do this one like this
is the one it says you need
if you want to do the special encoding
for your recording you need the 6000 or
newer
series one right here but the problem is
this doesn't work if this works i'm
gonna be
i'm gonna be because
when i was trying to do this originally
it kept saying
something like like one of the repos
wasn't there basically
but now it seems to be fine
okay well to my absolute surprise this
actually worked this time i don't know
if
something got updated on nvidia's end or
one of these little repos it goes to or
whatever but a couple days ago when i
tried this
it would it would do just a fail to find
and it would fail the download so now
that it's working i don't
know what to think anymore actually
but the whole point of that driver is it
was supposed to have
the support for nvec and i don't know if
it actually does yeah it's actually
installed now
am i gonna have to remake this video
it's everything i said before null and
void i don't know
well before what happened is this the
latest one failed so i had to use this
one
which is the 390 driver and didn't have
the uh
nvidia encoding special sport now this
one's supposed to have it
so what i might do here is just reboot
and try a few things out
and see what happens
[Music]
we're back we're back and oh my
is this video making me eat my own words
okay so i rebooted now
it took forever and i'm pretty sure this
is gonna happen
if i reboot again but it took like it
took like two minutes for it to boot up
it just sat there
a little a blank screen with a blinking
cursor at the top left forever
i assume doing something with the video
so
all right but something really amazing
happened now that that driver worked i
don't know why that driver finally
started working i guess they finally
sorted out their
uh link or something but now i do have
the in back encoder
all right holy crap
i now i don't know if this actually is
going to work correctly or what though
i guess we'll see but the invec encoder
is working and i love how i i started up
this video
to like complain about linux and now
it's just
absolutely destroying me and like
working great i really wish this just
would have worked a couple days ago when
i was trying it this was giving me such
a headache
and there didn't seem to be any solution
given that it just didn't find it
so i don't know what changed i'm going
to take a quick peek though and
see if there's anything obvious
vendor obs build proprietary x11 drivers
yeah i guess someone fixed it maybe
maybe i didn't have this distro up to
date
maybe i needed to click the uh update
and restart like seven more times or
something
i don't i'm not sure i'm not sure but uh
does seem to work now so so that's
that's good
okay let's see how steam does though
let's see
let's see if it lags like crazy when i
launch valheim or
or what happens because that could be a
telling factor you know
so let's launch valheim uh let's just
leave it default let's see what it does
on the default get out of my face steam
news don't do this to me
okay um
processing shaders
hasn't crashed yet usually this just is
instant crashes so
this is new it's running on vulcan
oh boy oh boy have we got it
see how see if she's laggy
strike crank and everything or not like
totally crank but
you know we'll go like yeah
turn on some of the stuff i want
looks good
just let me just fire up my world and
see what happens guys
valheim works really good on here
i might actually keep this os installed
i'm containing it but like i'm giddy
inside
i'm actually giddy holy crap look at
this
this is smooth oh my goodness so i could
you know if i wanted to i could be like
hey i'm gonna stream foul hype guys
and you could tune in and watch and it
wouldn't be a horrendous lag fest
it appears it's a punch of bush
yeah it seems pretty good
it seems pretty good
i'm impressed color me oppressed i'm
getting no sound though
sound output okay it's trying to
please i i don't windows does this too
it's something about this mic that i
have but
everything always seems to think that my
mic is a speaker
which obviously it's not so i think i'm
using
this one let's try valheim one more time
and see if just the sound works you know
that's all i want is the sound to work
yep if that works and runs smooth
that's a that's a big step in the right
direction
boom we got it
she's that's loud okay turn it down
yeah pretty safe to assume it's gonna
work fine all right
came to came to complain about linux
well that's going to do it for this
video hopefully you learned something or
maybe just had fun hearing me complain
and then get completely
owned by this os working way better than
i ever thought it would
don't forget to hit like and subscribe
if you like these type of videos special
shout out to my patrons
for being there for helping support me
and uh
honestly this i wouldn't have even made
my last few videos or a ton of videos
if it weren't for them so if you like
seeing these type of nerdy videos
consider becoming a patron click link
down below
it doesn't cost much pretty cheap it's
fine if you don't you know just hit like
there's other ways to support all right
i'm going to stop talking
and stop blabbing peace out guys see in
the next one
you